you
[Music]
thank you for
and I'm super excited and delighted to
be talking to you today and leading off
the shiny tract about effective use of
shiny modules in your shiny application
development you can follow along with
the slides at dot ly slash modules 2019
have a few links in there if you'd like
to click those as I go along
I'll lead off with a little bit about my
journey with shiny
I was one of the early adopters and when
it was first released the cran and like
Flynn here looking at the mess and
control program I was absolutely hooked
it is like a lot of you in the room I
started making small prototypes to
showcase not only to myself but to my
collaborators or colleagues
what shiny was capable of and learning
through examples along the way I had the
good fortune of attending the shiny Def
Con a few years ago and I have begun my
journey to slowly ascend Joe Chang's a
letter of enlightenment and fast
forwarding to today I am now a developer
of pretty large and complex applications
that often integrate multiple systems so
let me dive into my first attempt at one
of these types of applications what I
wanted to do with this application is
empower our sessions at our company that
didn't have any experience of our
programming to be able to use a very
sophisticated algorithm called subgroup
identification with a package that we
have open sourced Songkran called TS DT
we know how time to dive in and the
details of this package but the key
point is that this application had very
non-trivial requirements of having
persistent session management a dynamic
UI based on the data that was loaded by
the user and be able to integrate with
our HPC cluster so I encountered quite a
few challenges along the way i
duplicated pretty similar UI widgets
throughout the app I did not organize
the code well at all because I never
built anything this large in our in my
entire life before this point and
extending the features when SATA systems
would say hey can you do this can you do
this ended up being very challenging as
a result so I want to show you next kind
of a schematic of what the
components looked like and how they
related to each other you notice all
this mess of arrows right I have all
these relationships of inputs for one
module going outputs of another module
Nami and module these sub components but
it looks very messy
I've even duplicated these similar
widgets like variable selections or
visualization and frankly it gives me
flashbacks to a very good analogy put
out by Ian little of this is just a
reactive spaghetti mess and so how can
we get out of this what in the shiny
ecosystem can help us solve a lot of
these issues of managing this complex
application well since you're here you
probably not a surprise its modules to
the rescue this is going to unlock a lot
of possibilities but it's not just
unlocking that door its what do we do
afterwards
so the orient ourselves was talking
about what exactly modules are there's
quite a few ways of defining this but
the simplest way is that it's a way for
us to compose complex applications of
smaller and more understandable pieces
along the ride comes quite a few
benefits we are able to avoid namespace
collisions when we duplicate these
similar user interface widgets it allows
us to encapsulate or compartmentalize
these distinct components of our
application which in turn helps us
organize the codebase much better into
easier to understand pieces and that and
also is going to lead to facilitating
effective team development and if he
then check out Collin phase poster on
advanced shiny development he also
emphasized that same principle now take
a step back for a second I think this
sounds quite familiar if you're familiar
with our because our functions
themselves are a very important way to
avoid collisions and save variable names
with just general our code and they are
essential when you go from simple quick
dirty you know data analysis pipelines
to a more sophisticated and extensive
workflow like a lot of the packages that
you see today so let's imagine that had
modules available when I was making that
first complex application which was
admittedly well before modules came
around this is what it could look like
if I could go back in time and bring
present me back to then and architects
this in a much more logical way you see
these four MakerBot boxes here these
kind of mimic the workflow of the user
to visit this application degree of a
welcome interface they import data they
run the analyses on HPC and then they
interrogate the results but this doesn't
look like the spaghetti mess anymore
because I'm able to define very clearly
within these big boxes these sub module
relationships and also I'm not copying
pasting little sub modules in each of
these areas I'm able to encapsulate them
in the name space of these bigger
modules so I have to be honest with you
and did not arrive at this mindset right
away not even close it has taken me a
lot of practice and trial and error to
get to this kind of mindset so you can
think of it as we're on this highway to
in essence the mastery of modules this
is an ambitious goal but I imagine if
you're at least peripherally familiar of
modules you've probably been on this
first stop along this highway of being
able to create and use fairly simple
modules occasionally throughout your app
now I would challenge that I don't think
many people in the room are at these
points yet do you have a good handle on
how you structure the communications of
modules and even in more advance to that
communications between modules or
perhaps siblings of others we don't have
time to cover all this today but I'm
gonna show you a few concepts to get you
on your way that highway to those later
points near that very pretty sunset but
all of this traveling in this road to
mastery modules leads to these very
important principles first of which is
careful design think about these things
as you're developing a module such as
what does it do what is it trying to
accomplish and also what should I call
this thing now you may be wondering why
would I throw that in there well if you
can't name your module easily that's a
pretty big warning sign
it's probably trying to do too much so
you want to keep it fairly simple yep
you know accomplishing a common a very
powerful goal the other key principle is
thinking about your inputs and return
values what kind of inputs are you going
to have are they're gonna be static type
inputs or reactive inputs are how
complex do you want to make these return
values and which of these outputs are
serving as inputs the other modules is
kind of communication principle if you
take away nothing else from this talk
take away this modules that are built
without these principles is quite simply
not enough and I'm going to illustrate
how we can at least use these principles
effectively in practice so I'm going to
transition to a middle II a little demo
here of an application that we have
deployed on the shiny gallery and I
called the Ames housing data Explorer it
is using the Ames housing data set which
is available on cran and it lets the
user select these points with the plot
brushing after they choose variables and
then this shows up these metadata under
under word and then they can click that
checkbox and highlight those points
where the sales price so you can play
with that on the shiny gallery I'll have
links to that right here and the slides
if you want to play with that but now
let's look at how this is kind of
organized in a sense just looking at the
picture of this we have these sections
for the user selects variables we have
the section where of course the the
variables are being plotted in a
scatterplot and then we have that data
table below
that's visualized that's summarizing the
metadata of these results well really
these are all modules here we have a
variable module we have a visualization
module and we have that data table
module below so it shouldn't have been
there okay so let's talk about some
techniques to help get you into this row
to mastering modules more effectively
this first tangible item you can do is
of course documenting your modules now
here if you see on the top here I've
highlighted of course
input parameters they're not remarkable
here because this is a very simple
module but notice I am taking the act of
documenting doesn't have to be rocks
egde into it could be any system you
like but this is going to help you later
on when you start to use these in
practice I don't know why that is going
away I'm going to kill that okay let's
keep having so then look at the return
object of this as well
I've actually been intentional about
naming these components okay
vo soon you're going bye-bye let's do
that real okay we're back to business
okay so let's look at looks like is a
return module of the return object here
we have we have a name list in this case
X bar and y bar just simply inputs that
were taken from the UI I'm actually
being intentional here because this is
an example of you're constructing this
name list to articulate the intent of
this module my theme is like an accessor
type module but these end up being quite
important as you think about you know
making these modules simple yet can be
quite powerful I'm going to take a
little detour here to talk about more of
a development topic of modules to a
section that really even trips me up to
this day sometimes in this example we
have this little plot 1 VAR reactive and
we're just simply assigning that from an
input and then this mod module when we
call that we're supplying that plot 1
var is one of the arguments and within
that module server-side processing we
have a reactive not doing anything
special here it's just simply
referencing that plot 1 bar so keep this
in your mind a little bit as we talked
about when do we put parentheses after
these names and when don't we so I
believe a lot of you're familiar with of
course the tidy verse and things like
the per package and in base our Elif I
for those uninitiated the map function
takes this building this vector of stuff
and applies the function f to
each of these pieces notice that in the
map Paul were taking the name of that
function as the input but then we're
invoking that function on these pieces
individually you may be asking yourself
how in the world does this apply to
modules and shiney in general well it's
going back to this one oh i'm pseudocode
example notice that this call module
directive in essence is similar to that
map function where we're passing in the
name of that reactive without the
parentheses but then when we go inside
that module we're doing when we do it in
typical shiney when we do over-reactive
we're referencing that with the
parentheses inside but then when we have
that foo reactive we want to take that
back out we're not using that name again
now this is a minimally something that
you almost have to practice a few times
and even to this day there are sometimes
I get a little mixed up here and there
but I'm just sharing some of the lessons
I've learned that if you think about
these simple examples you can kind of
apply them to more complicated workflows
another stuff that we talked about back
in the principles slide is how do we
know where ever to use static or
reactive inputs to these modules so in
this code here I have this scatterplot
server module and it knows in the
documentation I'm saying that data set
parameter is a data frame that's
nonreactive and then within this plot
one Nobbs reactive I'm using that data
set name but without parentheses now why
is that it's because this data set if
you look at the code from that example
app it's simply the grab of the Ames
housing data from that package and it's
not changing in the app it's literally
just serving itself as the source for
where all my filtering from that plot
brushing is going to occur so this in
this case we only need that present
value because in essence is not changing
well let's not look at some of those
additional parameters in this case plot
one var and plot two VARs and if you
recall from the previous slides ago I
was informing that as a named list of
two components of X bar and y bar and
notice here I am using the parentheses
this time this is because we don't care
just about what the user so
initially but it's also what they will
select in the future and just like with
SHINee itself and we want to in want to
invoke these reactors we want to be both
present and future state in mind one
little nugget that can trip people up to
is when you have this name list that
you're returning from a module where do
you put those parentheses so in this
case you put it after that X bar Y bar
reference not after that list name
itself
I've spent a 24 more hours than I care
to admit of the bugging modules and if I
just made that fix it would have been
all done so hopefully I can save you
some time as you develop modules next
it's not just about what you should do
I'm gonna tell me about a technique that
you definitely do not want to do I am
someone affectionately call this the
kitchen sink approach so let's imagine
you have this reactive values object
called our data and this is a place
where in essence and each of these
modules I have in this application
instead of following that advice I just
gave you imagine I just want to have
these reactives here and there and when
I need to I just toss some stuff into
that reactive values object
who cares about returning anything out
of it because the best part is when I do
the module calls I just have that one
argument pertaining to that name our
data that reactive value slot boy seems
all rosy unicorns right well guess what
this is a bad idea because you've now
ventured into the dangerous world of
hidden state this is where it's
difficult to figure out what is
happening to these individual objects in
the our data kitchen-sink I will call it
and only certain objects from this are
needed as you pass from one module to
another and then what and even more
importantly it's losing that contract
that you've established with these
modules so this is a really bad idea
and even in baiting typical art
programming you wouldn't see people
passing around environments back and
forth fever that just as ugly stuff so
don't do it
so we've talked about a few things what
does this actually mean to you as a
shiny developer well I think you may
already know because are as I mentioned
is well-suited for inner
active workflows especially in data
science but then as he go from trivial
stuff that non-trivial workflows
functions are that essential building
block to make to move from these
different types of workflows and being
then defining clear function inputs is
essential for effective structure this
is no different when you create shiny
apps especially with modules in mind
because using modules with the
principles we've discussed is is an
important piece to bring software
engineering best practices to your
development such as determining the
purpose of the module and much of those
questions that we asked initially so
what's in it for you again recapping
some of the benefits of modules you're
avoiding namespace collisions for those
widgets you're organizing the
application into these distinct
components so you can facilitate
collaboration and more productive
development tracking down bugs and
you're using best practices that you
learn from your our our development
skills and translates very well with
modules so we have some calls to action
definitely read the new article that we
have on the shiny articles site for
module communication best practices and
keep your eye out for more articles in
the future in this space definitely
review the example application I've
shared on the shiny gallery for the Ames
housing data set but I want to mention
that this is going to be difficult to
get right the first time but just
persevere keep nudging keep reaching
eventually you will get there but it's
taken me a while but hopefully if you
think of these principles in mind it
won't take you as long as me so that's
that concludes my talk this is where you
can find me in the art community you may
hear my voice on a little thing called
the art podcast and I also try to be
involved with things like our weekly and
our Beynon and ever efforts so thank you
thank you we have approximately four
minutes so if there are any questions I
forgot to throw the throwable mic let me
go get that and then you can ask them
Thank You Winston has the throwable mic
so if you have questions look to him
have you been able to integrate modules
inside packages for easy distribution of
those modules sir
so I personally have not done it yet but
I've certainly seen examples in the
community where modules have been part
of packages so those there be some good
examples a follow on there for my use
case I've been preparing for that state
but because of our infrastructure I
can't deploy an application as a package
yet so that's part of it but we also
have situations where these modules are
kind of being used in my apps only but I
still use modules to help like the idea
as I mentioned keeping better organized
and make sure that I can debug them
easier and have multiple teammates
develop them concurrently but it could
it's certainly possible yeah that was a
great talk this is off topic completely
but I loved the our podcast but it was
quiet for a while so I stopped listening
are you back online episodes there will
be multiple coming from this conference
and I have ideas in mind they keep
that's the same Oh bye thank you for
those kind of work thank you Hey great
talk
meme game is strong today much
appreciated about that but my question
goes to along the lines of when you
create these modules is there a general
rule of thumb for how often you're
adding new functions into these things
or do they become like giant
repositories of
import functions or modifications for a
particular package or not package em you
know what I mean yeah yeah I get your
point
so I think it depends on how you're
structuring them one advanced topic that
I didn't really get to is that in my
applications I often have these larger
modules that are actually composed of
smaller modules inside so the idea is I
think it was like what does it work for
the user in your application and if you
can organize your app into components
whatever it's like tabs in the UI or
things like that those are great
candidates that have kind of like a
wrapper module and you have these more
utility modules inside that you can
reuse in different parts of your app but
I do Amit I do
some modules have quite a bit of
functions inside and some but I separate
those out into their own script and then
I can debug them effectively just as if
it was like in our package in that case
it takes a lot of practice though I I do
admit that
[Music]